hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
is the 8th of October you're watching
Gamespot news and today I've got stories
about things you can get for free and
stuff you should have been able to get
for free but now you can't let's start
with the
ladder a lot of you guys were really
pumped to play the free edition of Drive
Club on PlayStation Plus but due to
server issues it's not happening game
director Paul rinsky explained in a blog
post that the delay was necessary
because the servers are overloaded
Evolution studios are currently working
to patch the issues and the delay of the
free version of Drive Club has the
intended effect of easing load and
traffic to the game servers no word yet
on when this free edition might actually
resurface and in use of free stuff EA
want to give you a copy of Dragon Age
Origins no catch well except for having
origin that little orange demon aside
it's great to see EA on the house
promotional program offer up some
genuine genuinely good games Origins
will be free on origin for just one week
so if you want to learn all about the
origins before you crack into Dragon Age
inquisition come November this is a
really good time to do that I know a lot
of you hate origin but if you can
stomach it this is a good way to save
yourself a few bucks for a Stella RPG
halo the Master Chief Collection is
going to be at 1080p running 60 frames
per second pretty much that pretty much
part came through today as we learned
that the camp pain mode in Halo 2
Anniversary will run just short of that
60 frames per second at a resolution of
just 1328 by 1080 this is splitting
hairs at a ridiculous level of who cares
in my opinion but for those of you
lamenting that sweet sweet extra P the
reason the res is slightly lower is due
to the fact that you can swap between
the original and enhanced graphics and
sound modes on the fly so two engines
need to run at the same time to enable
that as for your question of the to day
let me know which EA game you'd like to
get for free through their on the house
promotion if you could choose that is it
for me today I'll be back tomorrow with
a bunch more news But be sure to have
yourselves a lovely day till
then